we invested at operating partners with
65 companies
uh as angels and wow over 100 companies
so
we do have the economies of scale in the
sense of seeing so many stuff
and repeating problems and then we can
also have connected people on the
network you just contact us with your
phone say oh
they had a similar problem let's connect
you to and he can help you
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring upward labs and hillel at
stanford i love it when serial
entrepreneurs turn to vcs bringing their
value and
insights to early stage companies meet
amit of nair
general partnered operator partners
amite is a general partner at operator
partners an early stage fund that was
started by amit and the founders of
flatiron health to invest and help
operators on their journey
prior to that amit was the founder and
ceo of taiki
until its acquisition taiki was backed
by top tier funds such as sequoia
softbank and eric schmidt's innovation
endeavors
amit of now welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you today
i am excellent thank you for having me
how are you i'm
i'm great thank you it's so cool talking
to you in the context of where we are
today because the last time we spoke i
believe was
maybe six years ago about potentially me
coming as an intern for taiki
i believe that i visited you in the
offices in tel aviv since then
taiki continued to grow in in amazing
ways
and uh through its acquisition and today
you're at you're oh you're running a vc
fund a
your general partner the operator
partners uh i was
shocked to read in one sentence you know
you ray you know the right the fund a
few dozen millions of dollars
the second sentence and the fund is
already invested in a whopping 57
companies i have no
freaking clue how that's even possible
but before we we talk about that
take me all the way back to you know
your childhood and your personality
because one of the things that i was so
impressed
you know when i in preparing for this is
seeing you know the engineering
mindset that you bring to everything and
your curiosity
and your you being a builder so so take
me all the way there
um awesome so fun being here um so i
think
that i was always building stuff uh
i put on my twitter bio that i like
really stuff with without lego vlogs
because i was always into building stuff
and when i was actually in high school i
started building websites
and uh i even went to college and i got
a college degree while i was in high
school
but i was interested in just building
stuff and i always view uh
programming as just the fun things you
have different blocks and you can create
different things which is a fun thing to
do
um so that's kind of how everything
started in high school
and then throughout the army service um
i kept being an engineer i served in
cyber like everyone else in israel
basically in tech
last time back to uh you're we're back
to the idf
that's where we stopped back to the idea
um
so in the idf i served in cyber like
everyone else in israel
um and when i finished with my army
service
um it was actually the first time i was
joining social networks and one of the
things i've noticed is
how how there's so much data out there
and how people post everything they
think about and dream about
and want and i just thought it would be
just a way to take this data and build
on top of it and that's how taki ended
up starting because
i just like and it wasn't oh i want to
start a company oh this
was more like this is interesting
there's a lot of cool data there let's
try to do something cool with it
right and so you're you're understanding
that you know the world is becoming
a big deal you know this realization is
coming at a time where
data is only starting to get accumulated
right when it's not you know today it's
pretty obvious that everything around us
is data driven but back then when social
social networks were just starting it
wasn't clear that literally every single
content we're creating is a piece of
data that you can learn from
correct was the first time that people
were sharing a ton of personal data or
thoughts
and you made it accessible because
before then you could have a website you
could have a blog
but that had a high bar for sharing a
status message or a tweet it became very
easy
and there's become abundance of data and
that's the interesting part in the web
over the last
10 or 15 years where there's abundance
of data that can help create new
products
right so tell me you know briefly run
down the the journey of taiki you're
raising capital from some of the most
incredible funds in the world you have
some amazing names but the my one of my
favorite
receipts is innovation endeavors with
the amazing george berman
and eric schmidt is a very close friend
and i'm not surprised at all that
taiki is in a portfolio there but what
what was sort of the vision
and and walk me through some of the most
exciting you know journeys
as an entrepreneur that you remember you
know the really interesting things
so i i love being an entrepreneur
building is fun and i do have to say
that each one of the investors we had
from sequoia israel marker innovation
endeavors
um softbank they used to do early stage
stuff everyone was amazing it's all
about
for me it's all about the people it's
about finding the people you want to
work with and you want to be in a
journey with and
every person that we that we had on this
journey
uh was just phenomenal and amazing um
for us when we started it was about the
data it was about the abundance of data
on the web and trying to use it to
figure out
trends using it when i saw the company
we thought should we go into fintech
should we go into ad section we're going
to help you to design products
and we end up going to uh marketing
which was like a
big deal when we started um
and the group the growth of the company
was phenomenal like within a year or two
i think we made a million dollars in
revenue the year after we made three the
year after we made nah
it was really really cool building is
fun i moved to new york i lived in new
york for 10 years
and it was just like fun for me the best
part about building a company was the
people
uh hiring amazing people working with
amazing people hiring people are
way better than me different things and
building a fun culture
i think one of the things that drives me
the most today is when i still meet
people who used to work at taki they
tell me it's the best workplace they
ever had
and they miss taking days and they want
to be digging again when are we doing
the next thing together
and just being having around amazing
people around you and working with them
is something that i
always loved and that's a big fun part
of entrepreneurship
was there a moment where you're as as
you're building think and i'm sure there
were many of them where you're
you're confused what you're saying like
i'm facing a challenge here
that i'm just not sure that i know how
to solve right now and
and it's time sensitive you have to make
a decision you're the ceo
people are looking up to you and all
you're thinking is you know i'm not sure
that i know what to do at this point
what do you do then so i think the dirty
little secrets about startups is that
from the outside everything looks
amazing you see this company is growing
super fast everything looks amazing
they're raising a lot of money but when
you look on the inside it's a bunch of
duct tape that's holding everything
together
and every company is always not just a
bunch of duct tape it's a bunch of
people where you have
imagine like the wall and there's a
water coming in you just
place your fingers and i think the game
is trying to move
fast enough to plug all the holes and
new holes come up and then you plug them
and you just keep doing this game
and i think the servers will win are
those who keep plugging the holes fast
enough before new holes come up
and that's kind of growth pains um so
the answer is that i don't think
you know um like you don't know anything
you just and every problem is so unique
for a company
except the general stuff of hiring
selling you have problems your product
your partners everything is just
different and i think it's about being
it's about doing it's about moving fast
about trying failing trying again
failing trying again until you succeed
so as long as you're fast enough to
deserve problems
then then you get good results hopefully
so you make a decision um
turning from entrepreneur to investor
but not just the typical
vc fund you're saying we're going to be
an early stage fund
uh we are not going to take board seats
we're going to help you
with all the operations in between board
meetings that is sort of the
you know the pitch as to the big added
value and you do that across
many many companies now what what what
was it about your experience
that showed you that this is something
that you know would provide a lot of
value to early stage startups
so um in the earliest early days of taki
we had really good advisors um and one
of them is zach weinberg who is now my
partner
in general in in operator partners and
he was he just sold a company called the
invite video to google and he was super
helpful for us
thinking about go to market and hiring
and interviewing candidates because
he was a few steps ahead of like ahead
of us
um and we became friends and as we
started doing things and
he started his new companies that aren't
health i helped him find his cto guilds
also one of my partners
and anna turner who was a uh
zack's uh co-founder both in invite
media and satarum
is always my fourth uh co-founder for
operator partners
we all work together for a long time and
we all invest in companies together
and we just try to help out and you see
that companies have similar problems
in the sense of growth so it's about
finding the right people
interviewing them how to think about
problems the problems are unique for the
company
but the the way you're thinking and
solving them is sort of similar and
repeating
and we end up realizing that we can
bring a lot of value to a company into a
ceo
by being advisors so we we used to get
equity for being advisors
now we invest our money to become
adviser of the company it's kind of the
way we're seeing it
right and so what is the actual you know
interaction that you have with the
companies first of all you're
you're you know you're spreading a lot
on throughout a lot of companies so how
do you maintain actually a handle
on on all these companies and and how do
how do you work together with the
entrepreneur to figure out
what exactly you can actually go into
the details with because at the end
the meaningful help is in the details
right it's in the actual problem that
they're trying to solve
so how do you go about figuring out the
priorities for that because it sounds to
me like that's one of the biggest
challenges that you might be facing
so we built a different model
in this model we decided we don't want
to compete with vcs because there's
plenty of really good vcs and we want we
don't
we're not competing with angels we're
coming in between and that means
that we need to if we invest small
checks you need to invest in a lot of
companies
but we also can invest all this time to
due diligence because it's really hard
if you want to invest in
60 companies so we work with a handful
of issues that we really like and trust
we trust their diligence we do meet a
company we do make our own decision
obviously and we don't invest in every
company we see
obviously um but um
but uh we simplify the process by
counting on someone else's diligence
when we do that we do meet a company and
we tell the sales look when we invest in
you
here's our emails here's our what's up
whatever you need anything
just come to us and we'll help you want
help interviewing your vp of marketing
or vp product how to find them
you want to think about uh m a you want
to think about
buying a selling company buying a
company just come to us
and we'll try to help and it's it makes
it super casual
we text with founders all day long and
then we need to we do a phone call with
them or video call with them but to make
it super casual we make it kind of
what we wanted to have when we ran
companies just like sometimes
it's more about just texting people
being in the loop and then things move
really really fast
so it kind of it also simplifies it
because we do get company updates like
that and we always kind of know what's
happening all the time so it's really
easy when there's a problem to
loop us in and when we try to help out
so what it sounds to me is that you're
taking the formality of the board
meetings that would happen on a monthly
or quarterly basis and you're
simplifying it
to a daily operation where you are
actively
helping a sort of like a day-to-day
board that is sort of an advisor sort of
a partner entrepreneur
and right i mean it's like all that
mishmash but but at the end it's very
tangibly helping them
with the day-to-day decisions that might
not even make it to the board meeting
because it's so far out
that it becomes irrelevant by that time
correct it's exactly that we're just
trying to give the immediate
quick solve for problems from our
experience and all we bring
is just like more of a crowdsourced data
of things we saw
we invested it operated by 65 companies
uh as angels and wow over 100 companies
so
we do have the economies of scale in the
sense of seeing so many stuff
and repeating problems and then we can
also help connect people on the network
you
come to us with a problem say oh they
had a similar problem let's connect you
to and he can help you so
that's all the value we can help and
bring and it is we want to be on the
entrepreneur side on the founders side
we've been there we just we just feel
like we know what we needed
and that's what we're trying to bring
back to the table right so
pattern recognition share with me a few
insights you've gained already by
you know through the companies other as
an angel or through the 65 companies as
operator partners
what what are you observing what are
some of the common
you know themes that are going on sort
of the common
decision making points that people need
help on because i think
it's it's a fascinating idea to to do
this at economies of scale and to be
able to see these patterns
across many different companies i think
the two interesting things i would say
everyone has the hiring problem hiring
great people is always hard
but but the interesting thing is it's
not about finding the great people
it's also funny great people are a fit
for you and it's something that
someone could have an amazing could be
an amazing person
might not be a fit for your company
culture so i think that's something
we do try to help people with to try to
understand their own culture and what
it's going to be a fit and not going to
be fit for their culture so it's
something that i think it's repeating
the other one is thinking about markets
correctly
so you know i'm not going to say
anything to
to uh revolutionary by saying you want a
great team in a giant market and then
you assume the great seam and joint
market will
will move around but when there's a
really giant market sometimes you want
to make sure you
focus on things in the market because if
it's really really we can do so many
producers you also spread today
so staying focused on everything if it
doesn't work keep giving you moving
around
but trying to be focused when you do
execute something
right now i mean the whole first part of
this conversation you're talking about
you know yourself
how you love the entrepreneurship and
you're meeting people that work to take
and they're saying we want to come back
and work on another company together and
how
you know exciting that whole journey is
and how excited you are by working with
early
entrepreneurs understanding what they're
going through and and
getting fulfilled from working with them
through those issues
isn't there a part of you that wants to
do it again that wants to start another
take
that wants to go on this whole ride
again of course there is
uh there's a big part i think uh one fun
thing is now i get a kick because i get
to spend
my week just meeting exciting
entrepreneurs and talking about fun
problems
and i do want to get uh but it's weird
because
first time in my life that i'm uh in the
back seat
and i'm not driving right it's different
i do miss driving
but i really really enjoy what i'm doing
right now and i think
the answer is that i'll find the middle
ground like i i will probably over time
get involved in a few companies
um maybe in a chairman role stuff like
that that will get me
way more involved um so i can i can
just get the kick off running of it and
you know what
maybe in the future i want to run my
company again i'm not i'm i'm right now
enjoying what i'm doing and i'll keep
adapting that i think the
entrepreneur of life just keep changing
into what you need at the same time
the right time completely and what is it
about operator partners that
you know that you're really excited
about is it the the partnering with the
entrepreneurs
is it more of the the capital side is it
more of the
the finding them and and seeing their
their journey throughout throughout the
years
well what really gets you excited about
this opportunity it's you know what it's
just
so much fun it's just about having fun
so
i basically work with a bunch of my good
friends they're super smart
we talk about interesting companies
together and we get involved in some
journeys that we like and
it's just fun and easy and it doesn't
feel like work i don't believe in
working taking never felt like work it
was
fun and this feels like fun just easy i
wake up in the morning meet cool
companies then talk to my friends and
talk and discuss at school companies
like what could be better than that
it's just fun that that's exactly what
it sounds like and i think that you know
that just from my perspective you know
seeing somebody who is a successful
entrepreneur
who's an engineer at heart was a problem
solving for sovereign heart
going from you know very technical to
building a company and then taking this
under these understandings and these
insights and moving on to scaling them
and doing them an economy of scale
and following i can't believe 65
investments you said
which is uh pretty remarkable and i i i
don't think i'll ever understand how you
how you manage to to juggle 65
investments especially when they're all
on whatsapp
but but i love the idea of a model where
it's more of
casual day-to-day deliberation it's
reducing the formality making yourself
accessible and you becoming a true
partner of the companies
yeah i think the one thing i have to say
though about juggling 65 companies and
we'll have a lot more over time
is that basically once you have a bunch
of people in the in the fund
and we each deal with different
companies they have difficulties
different times based on their needs
because we all have different expertise
it makes it's very easy and when you do
it over textbooks it's very very easy
um and i think that you'll speak to each
one of our companies and tell you how
much
we've been helpful and that's that's the
important part for me getting the good
uh
the good customer review from our
portfolio companies about being
we're being there when they need us so
as long as we can keep doing that
we're we're to be thrilled
and i have no doubt that they're that
they're very very happy amit
i i want to thank you so much for for
coming on the show uh
i have a some fun questions now that i
have to ask you
so what we'll go through them uh first a
role model
somebody that you find fictional or
non-fictional
somebody that you gain inspiration from
and why okay i'm gonna give you the
super cheesy obvious answer but
but it's going to be bill gates
and always as a kid i have to say i know
it sounds cheesy but as a kid
like it really inspired me to be an
entrepreneur like saying microsoft and i
think
microsoft it's a company that's really
enabled personal computing and the
internet as it's today
and then when bill gates became wealthy
enough he
took his qualities as an amazing
entrepreneur and put it into
into helping the world and building is
in building its non-profit organization
it actually helps people
and just love it it's like a real life
iron man in my opinion
um a real life iron man i love that okay
and now
favorite subject in school it can be any
school from kk
to post university um and it's cool i
i'd say english um and it's funny
maybe it's because my mom is an english
teacher maybe it's because i use english
all the time but i think it's one of the
reasons that
english is a fun class because when you
go to class
you need to learn the language and they
teach you you do different exercises so
it's very broad you learn some history
you learn some
you look you learn you learn some
history you learn some grammar you learn
just all kinds of different things
because you have to lose and you listen
to things you know
the content is just like listening to
podcasts because you have all these
writing essays and you learn how to
write
to me it's just such a swiss army knife
of uh classes because you do so many
different things in it so it's fun
i love it and the most difficult
question of all but the most interesting
one
three words that you would use to
describe yourself or if i ask anybody
that works with you
whether it's in taki or an operator
partners what
what what are what are three words that
they would say a meet of now
okay so my three words would be
optimism because i don't think you can
build company very interesting without
being optimistic
data i'm very data driven i think
everything i look at and decide is based
on data
and clarity which is
the importance of clear communication
organized
and having things very honest clear and
setting expectations
it's really really important to me
because i think if you communicate well
everything else is solved
i love it amit thank you very very much
this was just wonderful
and stay safe and stay healthy i love
the concept of what you're building and
again most of all i love the idea that
you're taking
your own passion as an entrepreneur and
you're channeling it through now
at an economy economies of scale to many
other entrepreneurs
and the the idea of just having fun and
and having fun
you know all across the board from the
due diligence side to the whatsapp
communication side
and getting those customer reviews from
happy entrepreneurs so thank you very
much for coming thank you for having me
thank you
you